I've said this a couple of times today I
think that like we've left a lot of
sweater threads is that it sweater or
little loose ends a little little dangly
dangly dangles that we're gonna come
back to wear no rush
yeah we're no rush oh my god they can go
anywhere they can do anything there's an
infinite amount of locations characters
and stories to tell so we'll we'll be
good to go for a while and I think when
we when we want to come back to
something really cool like like evil
Morty I want to make sure I know what's
his motivation
what's this backstory what's going on
and it has to be inspired and it can't
be forced and it can't be joyless it's
got to be like like something either I
come to the room and I and I go okay I
got really high this weekend like on
crack and like heroin and like I had
like eight hookers and like I came easy
boy I had this amazing idea where I
don't do anything I mean what you wanted
to come from a place that you don't want
it to circumscribe your narrative you
don't want you don't want to draw pin in
the whole show with an evil Morty
narrative you want evil if we've already
comes back he should be more like a bird
off winkler it's like oh I remember him
I think we got disconnected
Morty yeah don't Morty me I tricked Rick
into taking dad on an adventure because
I thought I could get a break from this
kind of but no like father like damn
daughter you want to be like Rick
congratulations you're just as arrogant
and just as irresponsible everything
okay here mind your own damn business
gene I'm having a conversation with my
mother
hey everybody as requested this is going
to be a new evil Morty video and there's
a new round of that merch giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
and I'll announce a new winner at the
end of this but like they said during
that interview they always leave lots of
sweater threads each season so obviously
that's something else to follow up on
after season 3 is done but more to their
evil Morty comments everyone's been
wondering where he is and whether or not
we're actually seeing something like
that happen over the course of season 3
the emergence of an evil Morty the whole
reason I included that clip from episode
5 is you get the sense that Morty is
starting to get fed up with everyone and
he shows the intelligence of trying to
trick Rick into something although we
learned that Rick knew that morty was
trying to get him to take jerry away but
it's a smarter version of morty than
we've ever seen like he's actually
trying to use Rick's tricks against him
so that he can just get some peace of
mind that's the really that comedy of
the situation is that he just wants a
break from all the bullcrap
not just Rick's bullcrap but we've
almost come to a full South Park style
situation where the children are the
ones that are acting like regular people
and all the adults are being crazy
although we do wind up meeting American
Psycho Morty in episode 6 so it's just a
way to sort of bring it back whether or
not you think it's the same version of
Morty so even though it seems like they
might be building towards something but
as Dan Harmon was saying like they don't
want to shackle their entire seasons
narrative to evil Morty they just want
him to show up organically and be like
oh he's off trying to bring his evil
plan to fruition in some other reality
it's not like this entire divorce
narrative is gonna get shackled to evil
Morty but a lot of people have now
started to look at the title of the
finale the Richter II and Morty date and
it just sort of reminded them of the
gravity falls episode the Stan cheryan
candidate where one character is
controlling another it's a very evil
Morty type device where they use the
electronic tie to control stand and make
him do everything that they want him to
do so
Manchurian Candidate is just the idea of
somebody controlling someone else to do
something rather sinister but is the
title implies it sounds more like Rick
brainwashing Morty is that sort of the
narrative of Manchurian Candidate it's
sort of a sleeper agent that helps the
other side and some sort of election or
take over a campaign so it doesn't
necessarily mean that we won't see evil
Morty it just sounds like when he does
come back it'll be a one-off episode and
it won't wind up being James Bond
Blofeld reveal I'm the architect of all
your pain Morty we're evil Morty is
somehow behind all the pain and
suffering of all the characters
regardless of their narratives so the
whole idea of season 3 though like
you've seen this divorce play out you've
seen a little bit about Beth's backstory
you've seen Sommer develop as a
character a little bit more the whole
idea about Morty with season 3 is that
he's becoming a much smarter version of
himself so he's got a long way to go
before he becomes an evil Morty because
for a very brief period evil Morty was
able to out Rick the Ricketts version of
Rick which as far as we know is still
our c-137 Rick even though his
consciousness has jumped into a couple
different bodies like I'm still thinking
of Inspector Gadget Rick as c-137 Rick
even though during episode 6 he winds up
creating a new body for himself so in
addition to all this smarter Morty's
stuff that we've seen played out we've
seen different versions of Rick in every
single episode
you go from pickle Rick to the dumbed
down version of Inspector Gadget Rick
back to a regular Rick that then
separates his toxic elements and Arie
combines them but through it all I still
think that it's the same consciousness
of c-137 Rick that just happens to be
jumping from body to body episode one
this season where he jumps into the
Garofalo meit's mind actually while
leaving pieces of his consciousness
behind in his old body and then jumps
back into his regular body as well as
the tiny Rick episode where he trashes
Project Phoenix is a good barometer for
how he feels about his physical form
like it's all about his consciousness
his intelligence just transferring from
one body to the other so I know there's
all kinds of ongoing theories about us
seeing different versions of the
characters in every single episode like
a different reality because of mr. poopy
butthole back during season 2 but for
the most part because of the ongoing
divorce narrative this season I think
we've been seeing the same versions
albeit in different bodies but there are
one-off
episodes like Episode seven is supposed
to be something of a one-off episode so
you could always look at that is a
different version of Rick and Maury than
we've been seeing during the divorce
storyline but just to bring it back
around to evil Morty like what is he
actually up to right now well the last
we saw is that he was actually really
just trying to overthrow Rick like he
saw Rick as this big universal constant
that was never going to change so
because there's so many of them on the
infinite curve it's literally infinite
it probably was just taking him a while
to work through all those different
Rick's and then you have our version of
rick c-137 that blew up the Citadel or
bricks so even though it seems like Rick
might be an endangered species in the
multiverse that's not actually the case
I mean infinite means infinite so they
could drag this on for another 97 years
till they get that Szechuan sauce which
they actually did get in real life which
is pretty cool but hopefully that
answers some questions about what's
actually going on with evil Morty this
season like I said they do keep a lot of
things close to the vest so it's always
possible that he could pop up but there
are certain ways that they're going to
bring him back and hopefully that
interview explains a little bit about
the thought process that goes into that
like they definitely want to bring it
back around to him but they're not gonna
shackle the entire narrative of this
season - evil Morty so what'll happen is
they'll probably be some more new Rick
and Morty later this week just leave all
your bonus video requests in the
comments below there's still a lot of
really cool stuff coming up this season
there are actually people that I know
that are associated with this show that
have said that episode 7 might wind up
being the fan favorite but they weren't
able to tell me anything about the
actual plot so it's still wide open to
theory crafting so congratulations to
the latest merch giveaway winner bill
Casey please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there'll be a new round
the next time I post Rick and Morty
while you wait for everything click here
for my episode 7 video and you can click
here for brand new Game of Thrones thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]